okay on the livestream that I did
yesterday there were lots of questions
about how strongly insurance companies
and pharmaceutical companies and
Republicans will oppose Bernie Sanders
new Medicare for all 2017 bill and much
of how strongly we see the opposition
activate against Bernie will be
determined by how serious or credible of
a threat to the status quo those groups
perceive Bernie's bill to be there's one
pharmacy EO named Brent Saunders who
runs a company called allergen it's a
huge pharmaceutical company he is
worried that Americans are going to
become so sick and tired of the current
system that they are going to get behind
a program like Bernie's or a similar one
to it he was in Boston last weekend at a
Wells Fargo conference and he was
talking about the low trust that exists
in the US for big pharmaceutical
companies from Americans and he said the
following about a proposal like Bernie
Sanders Medicare for all bill you know I
think we we've got to do things to bring
that trust back because ultimately
someone's gonna be in the White House
somebody's gonna be in Congress
someone's gonna be somewhere I'm gonna
have say enough snus let's just change
the whole system let's go to one payer
let's do something unless we really have
shown that this model works
it delivers innovation it delivers it in
a fair and appropriate way and there's a
good strong profitable company think
about what's being said here this is
being discussed among CEOs of big pharma
that people might say you know what
let's go to a single-payer system that
means that's having some impact and the
level of pickup and the level of support
is going to depend on messaging we
really know that right do you support a
government takeover of health care that
doesn't sound too good do you believe
the government has a duty to provide a
basic level of care to everyone
regardless of employment or ability to
pay huge support as Pat mentioned
earlier in the program drastic
difference even though we're talking
about the same thing is this a huge tax
increase Medicare for all or is it a
huge reduction in the cost of health
care it's no different it's the
same plan but what's the messaging the
fact that a big pharma CEO is saying
this behind closed doors Pat yeah is
huge speaking so candidly - and it's
like he's conceding two major points one
is that the American people are gonna
realize that enough is enough I think
they already have realized that and that
the for-profit health insurance industry
can't really innovate right I mean if
they haven't done it thus far they're
going to do it going forward probably
not I've been thinking about that which
is if you are a Republican that's
committed to the for-profit employer
connected health care system why not
work to make Obamacare work well from
the beginning Republicans have been
wanting to sabotage Obamacare or
sabotage to quote William Shatner yeah
anyway look that mean get that one look
that one up if really Republicans wanted
to maintain the improv the for-profit
employer connected health care system
why not work to make Obamacare work as
well as possible because again Obamacare
gives tens of millions of customers to
the for-profit health insurance system
not funding Obamacare or states refusing
the Medicaid expansion yet trying to
tell their residents that the reason
that they don't have coverage despite
being in poverty is because of Obamacare
rather than despite their ignoring of an
Obamacare opportunity called the
Medicaid expansion maybe from the
beginning big pharma and insurance and
Republicans should have realized hey
wait a second if this doesn't work we
might end up with something that makes
it even more difficult for us to collect
these insane profits but they never
think far enough ahead and I think bread
and Saunders understands the trend
that's happening because while this
Medicare for all bill is not going to
pass I mean we have a Republican
Congress and president after all you
know the waves could move it forward and
one day you know 10 years from now we
could be heading in this direction
even though it's republican-controlled
now yeah it could be Democratic
controlled very very soon yeah I talked
about that on the YouTube livestream
yesterday which is yeah we get this
isn't going to pass by 2018 it's not
going to pass by 2020 more than likely I
assume that Trump would probably veto
something like this although maybe not
because he seems to be willing to talk
to Democrats I'll talk
about that a little bit later in the
show but this level of official
co-sponsorship and and other support
from Democratic senators is something
we've not seen before and it is huge and
it's significant and it's putting the
plan out there for people to see oh it's
not some scary crazy communist
government takeover here are the
specifics of how it worked with work and
when you think about it it actually
sounds pretty good I'm on Twitter at the
Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show follow me there and we'll be
back after this
today's program is made possible in part
by taga dabbe the hosting specialists
they host websites for everybody from
bloggers to businesses to financial
traders you can get virtual dedicated
and private server solutions cloud
server solutions custom server solutions
whatever is right for your project or
business is available at taga dab and
with a growing number of people
increasingly interested in moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud
taga dab is offering our viewers and
listeners a twenty british pound free
credit when you sign up to give you a
chance to try out their cloud server
solutions this is a limited availability
offer first-come first-served for
viewers and listeners of the David
Pakman show
to take advantage go to signup tag
adhikam forward slash TDP s and use the
discount code TDP s 20 during your
account registration twenty British
pounds roughly twenty three twenty four
US dollars once again check it out
sign-up tag adapt calm /t DPS the
discount code is TDPS
twenty